au café du village Alban attend son
copain Guy le fameux leader de l'autre
camp 30 ans qu'il se retrouve ainsi mais
ces derniers temps le projet d'accueil
des réfugiés mais leur amitié à rue des
preuves
tu peux me mettre un café
tu peux mettre un café j'ai des sanction
de voix j'ai chanté hier à ma liste
peut-être un café ce matin tu as bu
assez de vin blanc hier
match du championnat
U23
il était bien sur la pelouse et il a
fallu des membres du staff vous voyez
essaie de le récupérer pour qu'il
s'envole et que le match puisse
reprendre
[Musique]
ça que j'imagine moi je suis pas de
galaxie
tu n'aimes pas les gens tu n'aimes pas
les gens mais non non
[Applaudissements]
Marine Le Pen est élu présidente de la
République sur un score sans appel de
54% contre 46% pour Emmanuel Macron
selon vos équipes selon votre sondage un
député RN se laisse emporter oui on va
gagner mais Garonne pas être entendu
parler à major un proche de Marine Le
Pen recadrera ce qui serait trop
peuphorique car le mot d'ordre est clair
gravité et surtout pas de triomphalisme
ce sondage nous oblige poursuit ce même
fidèle Marine Le Pen a d'ailleurs
elle-même écrit à ses troupes l'approche
du pouvoir doit entretenir notre sérieux
et notre travail on va nous éclater
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
arrête
allez salut allez va te saouler ça boit
beaucoup de ce bord-là
faire que tu as cité comment
vous voyez Marie
nous sommes tous amis sur ce plateau
mais de gauche voilà mais c'est plus
sympathique
la gauche vaut très au second tour dans
les mêmes proportions que lors de la
présidentielle en revanche les électeurs
de gauche au second tour ils iraient
largement s'abstenir Emmanuel Macron qui
est au milieu des déchets ça c'est une
vidéo qui a été créée il y a quelques
jours lorsque il y avait la grève des
éboueurs et que la capitale notamment
était inondée d'ordures le numéro de
Playboy qui la mettant une sort
aujourd'hui en kiosque qu'on y découvre
la secrétaire d'État à l'échoomi social
et solidaire drapé d'un drapeau français
dans les pages intérieures et le
figurant robe courte ou très moulante
mais pas nu bien entendu celui qui
recouvrira mon tatouage gagnera son
poids en zigounette et ça c'est du bon
on s'est dit quel serait parmi les gens
du appartement personnel politique la
plus Playboy compatible est
immédiatement un seul nom à surgi
c'était Marlène Schiappa bah j'ai
contacté
son bureau et là ils m'ont dit mais
pourquoi pas l'idée n'est pour être
sympa allons plus loin peut-être cette
médiatisation boostera des ventes en
demi teinte selon ce buraliste lyonnais
c'est un trimestriel et moi en temps
normal Playboy on va me réclamer de 1 à
3 magazines maximum chez lui deux
personnes ont tout de même déjà réservé
le prochain numéro une personne que je
connais qui est l'air plutôt féministe
et puis l'autre je pense un autre
intérêt je peux voir vous dire alors
l'interview de Schiappa se trouve coincé
entre une interview du zemmourice
Gilbert Collard un dossier drone et
vidéo proche une carte blanche à Ivan
rufold de cnews et du Figaro prend 30
secondes de votre temps est-ce que c'est
bon pour vous cette question n'a rien
d'anodine est-ce que c'est bon pour vous
le porte-parole du gouvernement reprend
l'expression préférée du vidéaste
Squeezie est-ce que c'est bon pour vous
j'ai l'allure que j'ai mais en tout cas
je ne ressemble à personne je ne cherche
pas à ressembler à qui que ce soit je
suis déjà Marlène Schiappa et c'est
assez difficile comme ça dernière toute
petite phrase et celle-ci non elle est
toute petite et celle-ci elle est jadère
totalement elle dit qu'elle essaye
d'être heureuse ne serait-ce que pour
donner l'exemple voilà
aujourd'hui on a quand même l'embarras
du choix on peut faire quelque chose on
peut tout plaquer aller à Bali et ouvrir
une start-up on peut faire des choses
donc pourquoi quand on a un travail qui
ne nous convient pas on vient pas leur
nicher et dire ça ne me convient pas
mais je ne bouge pas moi c'est un
discours qui est pour moi inaudible
[Musique]
chacun son truc quoi moi préfère ça dans
ma vie moi on va à l'école on apprend
l'histoire de Jean-Jacques Goldman là
Jean-François Seigneur 2 et on apprend
pas mais du papier peint à un moment
donné il faut qu'il nous apprennent des
trucs de la vie non mais c'est vrai je
vais inventer une nouvelle école il faut
revoir l'éducation là parce que mon
comment on va faire pour ça maintenant
c'est effrayant